we're gonna move on from this I just
want to say that John Jones lost that
fight now he did you would agree yeah
yes I got three two three two two one
the last two rounds that's right yeah
you got John first round I mean got
breas first round second round the round
I can see it a little dicey oh really
okay see the rounds though like not
clear from here okay that's well that's
where controversy comes well then you
know what you gotta take for Li you
gotta say the bottle with from the champ
that he dumped you don't want any other
state you and he'd walk away the winner
well can I see this when one of judge
does judges the first round don't they
give that card to somebody so they don't
they can't I think they they once they
judge the first round they go that's
around and they give it to someone else
who's neutral I think unless they unless
they tell you at all at the end tell you
know did they do yeah that's not how
boxing works because boxing they'll
judge the first round boom they come
there well and you see on the bottom the
card the word that's in like the numbers
are typed in then the rest is written in
right I the way Tommy Gray has fought a
great fight moving laterally kept moving
never let John get off he looked great
and he's a better boxer probably and
hits harder I don't know can say
anything that John's the most successful
light heavyweight of to ever do it so
he's a better box I'll tell you this I
think I think you're a better thing
raises every bit the athlete John is
probably would you better athlete you
know he's a better athlete not a better
fighter Oh better say better okay so
he's a serious athlete yeah as you could
say he was one double-a ball you know he
likes done yeah team captains Wow
football football big ding I didn't
write it any like NFL camp or anything
but they start training fighting well
there you go and and southpaw I believe
he knew both yeah you stud started and
hasn't been fighting that long ago right
that's just 13th fight it's not a lot
Wow no yeah I think they fight again
John's got some problems and I'll tell
you something else no I tell you
something else I think if John tries to
fight steep a message I think he gets
knocked out and all due respect you off
the John I know this is Emma Mayen Jen
all the trainers know I'll do my mouth
dude no matter
all due respect to John Jones who I love
all dice's respect if he fights see Pam
you said she gets knocked out and I'll
break it down for you
steep em usage is going to if if John if
John if Stevie gets John against the
case the way he could you race gets John
is the case steep it hits so hard and I
think he's gonna connect the knock him
out if it gets into a boxing match which
it will because I don't think John can
wrestle with he can wrestle with steep a
but he's gonna have just as much trouble
or more trouble with steep a because
he's a better wrestler than rares
so then the wrestling gets neutralized
you got that front kick you got that
step that that thigh stomp
I think steep a closes distance on that
and then now it's a boxing match and he
gets in a boxing match steep a wins sure
and that you should bring this to
Stallone's house and they're gonna love
it you don't agree with that do it you
don't agree with that here at home when
you do it here yeah so he saying
wrestling's neutralized yes go off let's
just start with your first greatman
neutralize yeah would you say DC's a
better wrestler there CP yes I would
okay John took him down I understand so
that doesn't the neutralize that
whatever didn't take down Reyes great
dia takedown defense hold on hold on
let's just go off fat okay took him down
didn't control him stood up her also
took him down in the the fourth and
fifth because he was losing the fight
that's how you know Dom was win the
fight
yeah cuz once I saw him saw John shoot
right he knew his Ryan's in the fight
that's why I shot correct he could have
took him down and whenever he wanted but
he realized he was losing down on the
scorecard so he started taking Ryland he
takes T PI down anytime he wants
well again took DC down - Gus turned
down yeah - again much more a credible
credible wrestlers not as big I think
that plays a factor I think state pays
big I think he's excellent wrestler so I
think what happens is if they get into
clinch if they get in a clinch game I
I'm favoring steep a if they get into a
takedown thing it's gonna be tough to
take steep it down I don't think here's
what I mean
I don't think John's takedowns are a
threat anymore a threat to see pay then
to anybody else
or less so so I don't think steep-ass
the game plan for that takedown is I'm
saying no okay so you know John has the
most takedowns ever in light heavyweight
history light heavyweight not
heavyweight
big difference and so you know DC beats
t-pain John beat him twice yeah yeah and
steep a nacht wait I'm sorry it's deep a
knock DC out yes DC not sleepy I'll
reverse that DC naught CP out then steep
a knock these correct John beat DC twice
right once my head kick yeah oh yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be interesting
I'm stammers I'm usually represent the
MMA community no a guy has a little bit
of trouble and was like he's beetle all
he's very well now it's boys beatable if
we're a guy like Steve Bay I think if
they get in okay I think it's gonna come
down to a fisticuffs and if it does I
believe steep a knocks Jonah know and
that's and that's not saying I'm not
being disrespectful I'm just saying that
I I think that's a steep a is he knocks
so many people out he's got that he's
just so [ __ ] powerful I think he
probably hits harder than Reyes I think
that's fair to say
just buy it have you wait yeah and I
think that you know you can't I I
believe also though John may adjust I
think John's highly intelligent and
he'll be he'll adjust and not maybe
fight the same way he fought against
Reyes game plan hmm
but you know John's never lost a rematch
ever destroyed finishes the guy who time
the day did that with Gustafson will see
NDC Astra hmm it's like I'm talking to
MMA for him right now no everyone's like
I'm out he's older I didn't say these
beats the [ __ ] I didn't say he beat such
as they bit well well I guess we'll take
it we'll have a gentlemen's bet on that
because I'm saying slow gentleman's bet
I'll bet you five grand okay and I don't
want to go crazy cuz it's MA and you're
not gonna pay no no but but I of steep
it will knock him out that's not saying
I think the thinking they're gonna get
into a boxing match and I think I don't
think anybody can handle steep ace power
and I think it's gonna get into that I
think it's gonna get into a boxing match
cool man yeah and you disagree with that
I'm just not on the train of Oh John you
know John's he'll lose his next fight or
any of that I I think I think Steve I
think he's fighting the best heavyweight
of all time in some ways a heavyweight
that's I'm not saying he's gonna lose
his next fight he's fightin steep a
meiosis you know I know I know
do you know what's going on with Steve
in our design and
and all that I don't I haven't fought in
a while so when you go when you go off
like someone who's like as far as like
aging steep a would be the the more long
and the tooth as far as how old a steep
a bike you know he's a firefighter yeah
he's got some Ward that was that died he
why I didn't like the way he was talking
after the 37 huh that's out there
how old is John 32 I believe 32 33 I'm
using you but the thing is there's not
to worry about the a drop see he's
definitely younger but just as far as
damage taken yeah it's a lot of damage
right there's a lot of damage there
so I lords with his wars with JDS like
those were yeah man yeah Overeem fight
was tough like there was he's had some
wars wars again you there's only me is
the greatest every weight of all yeah
that's all I'm saying and I think that
and I think he's boxing is you know what
it looked like to me honestly it looked
like John wasn't willing to I was like
why isn't he jabbing why isn't he
throwing shots
I might might I think what happened was
they were like look rays knocks
everybody out don't get into a boxing
match with him kick kick him keep him at
a distance pick your shots which made
sense right so because they were in
boxing distance I was like why John not
getting in these but then I saw Reyes
dipping and throwing up or counter
fights up yeah yeah yeah and I was like
Jesus okay that makes sense because I
couldn't figure it out and then I was
like well he's gonna you don't wanna get
into a brawl with that guy because he's
really powerful so that's that's what
I'm saying and I I don't know I don't
know how if they I don't know how they
how they avoid getting into boxing
distance and now now I favor steep a is
that fair I mean I guess I John's the
greatest of all time in boxing distance
maybe Gusman who have seen annihilate
heavy world-class heavyweight boxers in
the acting he's the you know he's making
John John's it's amazing after one fight
you're acting like I'm dissing John I'm
not no I'm acting like you you I don't I
don't know if maybe it's because you
because you start drawing about class
and box
I didn't got out of class at all because
I blanked I think that I think that his
camp probably said don't box with him
kick out his SS now I think Dom was
moving so much yeah he was he's moving
non-stop so yes just you keep saying the
smartest smart way to hike yeah very
smart way to fight him just kept moving
back and forth and all that I was
[ __ ] smart yeah the Dom like
phenomenal man yeah phenomenal he did I
will see hopefully that's a fight do you
know I can get the rematch UFC doesn't
do rematch is really you're not getting
a rematch I don't think so but and I
don't I don't think he goes well for Dom
when they rematch it's just cuz trying
to which the way you were gonna beat him
that was your one time to do it and then
it's like it's over man
well that that makes sense because John
was clip was winning if four and five I
think
oh yeah well he had won things yeah no
one gave Dom yeah and if three was up in
the air then then it was a good decision
well yeah you've got a champ
I gazed a champion seeds I don't mmm I
don't do that a five-round fight a
five-round fight whether it's on the
prelims or what it doesn't matter yeah
it's a fight Dom won three other first
time I've ever seen John John's lose
manures it's the first time so Reyes
didn't that Gustin fight was almost that
was close the santos fight was a split
decision yeah he's fighting dogs dogs
dogs now I would argue that John didn't
take this fight serious oh I'm not
taking anything Dom did but I would
argue that John was out at the Super
Bowl festivities the week before now
what he did I don't know but if I have
the biggest fight of my life coming up
which every title fight for him is a
beast lady's life I'm probably not to me
in Miami at Super Ball it's are taken in
festivities very interesting very
interesting I I do I think it's hard for
John to get up for these fights I really
do really mm-hmm
sacré not big names he's just like I'm
so much better these guys yeah whatever
I think he's getting older and these
guys are young and talented Dom so
talented so even though you know the pub
hasn't afford one dog but Dom has all
the skills yeah if John hangs around
long enough that it's gonna catch up
with him I'm sorry
okay three summers of caught fights in
any other state John loses and that's
judges prizes that's all my thing is if
you give them steep a in the world
heavyweight title is on the line
training do you think John's gonna get
up for that fight yeah I do
I'm very excited about that fight I hope
they do it I don't know you don't think
that you think there's a chance they
won't I don't know who knows what the
UFC's gonna do this here it's really
what John he's defended his 205 title
like road and said he's more than
anybody else's 14 will hold up defended
the title more than anybody take her on
a team ride over 14 times that's
incredible
so he's the greatest fighter to ever
step into the Octagon yep without
question
so if he beats steep eh I'll build a
[ __ ] shrine to him yeah hopefully
they do it hopefully steep a wants it
like it did be fun man I hope it happens
yeah I'm not too interested in the
rematch I don't know I I so Stevie's got
an eye issue
he took up beating with that there's
something going on with his body it's i
right Charlie's I was cleared though and
then he still didn't want to come back
he's saying he wants to heal it more and
that's why Daniel Cormier was like come
on what are you doing like we should get
this fight back it was no match Jesus my
issues nothing joke around is it's not
good again he said some wars dude great
fight though great fight loved it
excited I'm saying it's deep a job a
great fight mm-hmm right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]